la escasez de agua se siente cada vez
más en brásil la peor sequía en décadas
está causando estragos en el sector
hidroeléctrico con los niveles de
reservas más bajos del último siglo el
país se declaró en emergencia hídrica en
mayo y la falta de lluvias ha empeorado
la situación por lo que el gobierno
pidió el miércoles a la población
reducir el consumo de energía una crisis
que ha disparado el precio de la
electricidad en diciembre pague 850
reales pero para ser más exacto 848
reales en la factura de la energía es
email este mes la factura es de mil
doscientos veinte reales utilizando el
mismo número de congeladores sin cambiar
nada
el precio de la energía ha aumentado
mucho es difícil trabajar trabajar
brasil la nación con más agua dulce del
mundo ha perdido el 15 por ciento de sus
superficies de agua desde 1991 con el
cambio climático y la deforestación como
las principales causas de que los ríos
se estén secando hemos perdido el 15 por
ciento de la superficie del agua del
país destacan algunas regiones como el
pantanal el mayor humedal continental
del planeta y el más afectado por el
cambio de dinámica hídrica con una
reducción del 74 por ciento de su agua
un tema delicado para el presidente
bolsonaro que trata los asuntos
climáticos como algo secundario y se
muestra reacio a imponer restricciones
de consumo energético para no manchar su
imagen de cara a las elecciones del 2022
no obstante los expertos advierten que
la sequía podría persistir por meses